[Musique]
attention ah oui il ya sous les yeux ça
et là le gardien mais gaza et les
biotopes wingardium leviosa gardiola nom
de radio sa j'adore
bonjour j'ai besoin d'un peu de
pétillant l'invité le même effet c'est
comme quand tu vois jamais justice pas
si missouri lautner
bakou
saïd était aussi son roman mais après ça
nous mène au maillet to man who made who
ya sept ans le yacht à dix contre onze
c'est quoi ces églises des années 80 et
de culotte avec anne caudal at on a
cassé à laquelle sextape franchement à
la baisse que de rigueur
c'est le sucré d'hermach à wil histoire
il se connecte marc grubica j'ai traité
par téléphone est très très amont du
tabac qui est donc très cher
qui est donc très cher ça c'est leur
[Musique]